so
that's up to this point inflation we
think we expect as i said we're still
waiting for those figures to drop i've
just got them here uh now for you so uh
the cpi that's the consumer price index
rose by 9.1 in the 12 months to may so
that was precisely what economists were
expecting tipping up a little bit there
from the nine percent we had nine point
one percent inflation that's huge and
everyone's feeling it in their lives you
might ask okay we're wearing a big huge
jacket and a cap here i'm actually at a
food importing business we're in a
children so this is a a big warm coat
we're quite cold in here at the moment
things will start waking up here shortly
essentially lots of trucks coming in
from europe bringing fresh fruit and
vegetables they'll get repacked and sent
around the uk the big cost they're
facing we all are is fuel costs their
fuel costs up 30 and that explains a
little bit as to why the food that we're
buying is rising so much in cost
everyone's feeling it in their lives and
these figures really uh demonstrating
that 9.1 inflation in the months to me
yeah um last time uh you brought us
those figures you were with me up in
wigan who knows where you're gonna be
next month for now thanks very much
thank you